[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the British may have already
nailed Trump on Russia on tape no not
that tape it was the 34th and final
paragraph in a long and pretty staid
review of the role British spies have
played in connecting the dots between
the Trump presidential campaign and the
Russians and then as if it were merely
the best available way for Britain's
newspaper The Guardian to end its useful
but fairly modest story came paragraph
34 quoting one source suggested the
official investigation was making
progress quote they now have specific
concrete and corroborated evidence of
collusion the source said this is
between people in the Trump campaign and
agents of Russian influence relating to
the use of hacked material Oh shouldn't
that have been presented I don't know a
little more prominently quote specific
and corroborated evidence of collusion
quote between people in the Trump
campaign and agents of Russian influence
quote relating to the use of hacked
material not only did the Republic not
grind to a halt
after that but nobody not even the
Guardian itself followed up with the
appropriate screaming headlines
no screaming headlines even in light of
what Eric Trump had told another British
newspaper The Daily Telegraph in the
wake of his father's impotent missile
attack against that Syrian air base if
there was anything that Syria did the
Trump spawn protested too much it was to
validate the fact that there is no
Russia tie no screaming headlines not
even as a British magazine prospect
quoted the nation's former chief spied
Richard Dearlove
as speculating that quote what lingers
for Trump may be what deals on what
terms he did after the financial crisis
of 2008 to borrow Russian money when
others in the West apparently would not
lend to him no screaming headlines even
as the Washington Post reported the FBI
did indeed get a judge to issue a FISA
warrant permission under the Foreign
Intelligence Surveillance Act to track
the actions of and communications with
actions by Carter page who was the
second name Donald Trump ever Gabe when
he was asked to his foreign policy
advisers were no screaming headlines
even though the story that the FBI had
sought and gotten a FISA warrant of some
kind against somebody directly linked to
Trump and/or his campaign had been
widely reported in non-traditional media
ever since the former British Member of
Parliament Louise mensch published a
sourced story before the election
no screaming headlines even though the
essence of mensches November 7th story
was that while looking at suspicious
Russian banking activity foreign
intelligence services had tripped over
contacts between the Russians and the
Trump team and the FBI needed that FISA
warrant because without it they couldn't
even read what say the British had
apparently come up with quoting her
story it is thought in the intelligence
community men Schroder November that the
warrant covers any US person connected
to this investigation and thus covers
Donald Trump at at least three further
men who have either formed part of his
campaign or acted as media surrogates
mensches report was not so much
dismissed then as it was ignored
now ms mensch is back on her own blog
Sunday night sources with links to the
intelligence community say it is
believed that Carter page went to Moscow
in early July carrying with him a
pre-recorded tape of Donald Trump
offering to change American policy if he
were to be elected to make it more
favorable to Putin in exchange page was
authorized directly by Trump to request
the help of the Russian government in
hacking the election well you have to
admit an audio recording of Donald Trump
personally saying he would trade
American policy decisions in exchange
for nefarious Russian intervention in
the election would probably fit the
Guardians 34th paragraph about specific
and corroborated evidence of collusion
between people in the Trump campaign and
agents of Russian influence relating to
the use of hacked material Mensch also
alleges three Trump associates named in
the FBI FISA warrant application
russian-born former Trump TV spokesman
Boris Epstein former Trump campaign
manager Paul Manafort
and Carter page quote a recording exists
of all three men discussing the
possibility of Paige taking the tape of
Trump to Moscow as an earnest of good
faith there is a minor dispute over
whether Trump himself is also on that
tape
so if mention is right there may be two
tapes of Donald Trump personally making
a promise to a foreign government to
help it out if that foreign government
broke American laws in order to get him
elected here in the abstract in the
theoretical that would be treason on
tape without endorsing or even agreeing
with everything ms Mensch has ever
reported or suggested it is noteworthy
that where her newest reporting has
again been dismissed three principal
criticisms have been raised first that
she was not exactly right when she was
the first to report the FBI had gone to
the extreme lengths of seeking FISA
warrants against the Trump team before
the entirety of the world's mainstream
media was even close to the story The
Washington Post just got last week
secondly there is the disbelief that
anybody would be stupid enough to not
just leave specific and corroborated
evidence of collusion of Trump saying
let's make a deal but to actually
deliberately have created that evidence
well if you have seen Carter page
interviewed you should have no doubt
that he is stupid enough to have done
something exactly like this in one
interview about the question of whether
or not he had ever met the infamous
Russian ambassador kiss lyac he managed
to contradict himself about five times
in about five minutes before finally
confessing that he had with the immortal
words I may have met him possibly it may
have been in Cleveland and of course if
you've ever heard Donald Trump talk and
forget which country he had attacked the
week before but remember what kind of
cake he was eating while he was telling
the president of China about that attack
you should also have no doubt that he
too is stupid enough and more relevantly
so convinced of his own invulnerability
to have done something exactly like this
and indeed this underscores my repeated
contention here that democracy has
survived less because of the hard work
and dedication of people like you and me
who are committed to
it's preservation and more because of
the unfailing and eternal stupidity of
those who would destroy it but lastly
and most importantly Louise benches
story has been criticized because no
matter how unfailing and how eternal
that stupidity may be who could ever
rise to the position of president of the
United States no matter how insane or
paranoid or certain that the ordinary
odds that they might get caught did not
apply to them
no president would be stupid enough to
put it on tape Richard Nixon resist
peace